[MUSIC]
One morning, six years ago, I woke up
with an overwhelming feeling of dread.
I was beginning to feel more and more
suffocated by my life as an accountant.
You see, I had chosen this life, but
I felt no sense of meaning,
no sense of purpose.
Not only was I unfulfilled,
but I was falling apart.
And as I showered that morning,
I thought to myself,
if I died today, it wouldn't be so bad.
I went to work that morning.
I sat at my desk and I work on my
spreadsheets like I did every other day.
And at the end of the day, I packed up
my stuff and I drove to go back home.
But on that specific day on
the drive back, everything changed.
As I was going down the freeway
at 70 miles per hour,
a big white truck that was in front of me
swerved to avoid a broken down minivan.
I didn't have time to get out of the way,
so
I crashed head first,
into the back of a car.
As the windscreen shattered,
I closed my eyes and
braced myself as my car was flung
viciously into oncoming traffic.
And in the chaos and noise,
the first thought that came to my head was
thank God,
I don't have to go to work tomorrow.
As you can see I'm standing
in front of you today.
I survived but in the days and weeks that
followed I thought to myself, what was
the point of surviving only to go back to
a life that made me feel like I was dying.
And perhaps my case is extreme, but
maybe you felt something similar.
A lack of fulfillment in your job, a lack
of fulfillment in your relationships.
Just going through the motions,
surviving not quite thriving.
Living not a full life, but a half one.
And after my accident,
I realized yes we're given life,
but we also have to choose it for
ourselves.
You see we hear these stories of
work that doesn't feel like work.
We hear these stories of epic and
beautiful love and if that was true,
I wanted that for myself as well.
As Thoreau, the great poet once wrote,
I wished to live deliberately.
I did not wish to live what was not life,
nor did I want to practice resignation.
I wanted to live deeply and
suck all the marrow out of life.
That is my intention.
I didn't know how I was going to do it,
but I was determined to figure it out.
A couple weeks later, I stumbled upon
an interview with Oprah and Gary Zukav,
author of the New York Times best
selling book, The Seat of the Soul.
And the core message of the book struck
right to the center of my being.
It said, in order to live an authentic and
fulfilling life, you have to align
your personality with your purpose.
In order to live an authentic and
fulfilling life, you have to align your
personality with your soul's purpose.
And according to the book, there
are three key step to make that happen.
First, uncover your personality.
So who are you deep down inside?
What are your values,
your motivations, what lights you up?
Two, use your personality
to find your purpose, and
turn that light from within outward
to be of service to other people.
And third, take steps every single day to
live that personality and that purpose.
So step one, uncover my personality.
What would the person that I wanted to
become have to do to live a life that was
true to him?
After much thought,
I knew what my first act had to be.
I would have to reveal to my
parents that I was what they,
as Africans, would call evil.
Unnatural, of the dark side, un-African.
I would have to reveal to
my parents that I was gay.
And I say this as if it was easy,
but it was incredibly difficult.
But I was determined to not
hide any parts of my identity.
And during this time, I decided to leave
my lucrative, but painful, accounting job.
And despite strong
protests with my parents,
I took three months off to travel
alone to seven Asian countries.
I was seeking some kind of fulfillment,
some kind of awakening.
And as a way to capture and
share those experiences,
I decided to film a video blog.
And to my great surprise,
I discovered my deep, deep love for
using video as a way to capture and
share experiences with other people.
>From hunting down the most delicious
ramen in the backseats of Kyoto,
to trying to recreating my very
own Eat Pray Love moment in Bali.
Which, by the way, is not a thing.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But I felt fulfilled, I felt alive.
You see, video allowed me to show and
not have to tell.
To be, and not have to perform.
I could just be my most authentic form.
Who would you be in your
most authentic form?
What would you be doing?
What purpose might you stumble upon?
You see, as I created these videos I
felt something I hadn't thought before,
a deeper sense of connection to the young
Africans that were watching my videos.
This was step two in action.
My commitment to uncover my
personality led me right to my purpose
which is to inspire and entertain
young Africans through online video.
There is nothing else in
the world that I'd rather do.
What I know now in hind sight
is that it's the commitment.
The commitment to wanting
a better relationship.
a more fulfilling job.
The commitment to finding your
purpose is the most important step.
As Gerta,
the famous German writer once wrote,
until one is committed, there is
hesitancy, the chance to draw back.
But the moment one definitely commits
oneself, then Providence moves, too.
You see, when we commit we see things
we otherwise wouldn't have seen.
We make connections we
otherwise wouldn't have made
the moment one commits oneself,
then Providence moves, too.
So what did I have to do next?
I had to figure out what
I was going to commit to.
What are you willing to commit to today?
Right here, right now.
Before my accident, I was lost and
hopeless as an accountant, but
after my travels, I felt alive, I felt
fulfilled, the feeling was cellular,
I could feel it, it was real.
When you commit to uncovering your
personality and your purpose,
I have no doubt that that is possible for
you, too.
That brings me to step three.
Discovery of your purpose is necessary,
but
not sufficient to live an authentic and
fulfilling life.
You have to take the steps
to live it every single day.
So because I like online video,
I set my sights on Hollywood.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The lights, the camera, the action.
But from my home in South Africa,
Hollywood seemed too far away.
And I could have stopped, but I didn't.
I had committed.
And what I know now is that the most
successful people just start exactly
where they are.
So I started my very own YouTube
show with my best friend, Lindy.
Dedicated to sharing stories with young
Africans just like myself, everything from
serious to funny topics, like interracial
dating, what it means to be African
in modern times, and even the trials and
tribulations of black girls' hair.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I know it's easy to just say,
I'll just start my own YouTube show,
but it's incredibly hard.
You see,
building an online following is tough, but
facing my inner doubts and
outter critics is even harder.
>> To this day,
I still receive homophobic comments.
Things like why would you share this
video with me this guy looks scared
I don't want to see stuff like that,
and what that has tought me is
that authenticity is not all upside
>> You will get beaten
down in the process.
But instead of feeling like I was dying,
I was living.
A show that I created in my
bedroom was watched by over 10,000
people in 150 countries.
The show has paved a brick
road of blessings for me.
I have so many supporters
who have become super fans,
some who have even become friends,
and one of those friends is Laura.
Laura is a super fan from Zimbabwe,
and because I like to get to know my
super fans,
I set up a time to Skype call with her.
Little did I know the impact
this call would have on my life.
It turns out that Laura
is a little person.
And that because of the show,
she was inspired to start her very
own YouTube show and the Little People's
Association for Zimbabwe, a place for
little people to come together,
share stories, and inspire each other.
She told me that because of my show,
she knew that she was enough.
As Marianne Williamson, the author,
once wrote, as we let our own light shine,
we unconsciously give other people
the permission to do the same.
When we choose life,
we unconsciously give other people
the permission to do the same.
I went from being
a miserable accountant and
now an inspired YouTube produce with a
mission to light up other people's lives.
I'm even building a company
with that mission.
Who are you now?
Who could you be?
With a commitment to uncovering
your personality and your purpose,
imagine what you could do,
how big you could play.
And in the time since my journey began,
I've learned that playing big in the world
doesn't have to mean being the CEO of
the next best startup in Silicon Valley,
or Beyonce at the Super Bowl.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Or starting your very own YouTube show.
We can choose to play big every day
by having the courage to choose life,
by having the courage to uncover
our personality and our purpose.
Because once you commit to choosing life,
I can assure you that Providence
will move, too, and your light will give
other people the courage to do the same.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]